hello everyone this game comes as a
suggestion from a subscriber you on it
man and he suggested a game between how
he put it original tile versus
Yugoslavian towel and I was very
impressed by his suggestion since I
really enjoy games by Michael Tao of
course and but I also enjoy games by
derogative le meter each now I don't
know some of you may remember some time
ago I think it was like two months ago I
did a video on one of photography miura
which is games and in that video I also
said a few words about him and
introduced him properly so I will put a
link to that video in the description
below be sure to check it out as a drag
equivalent mirror which serbian
grandmaster in those days he was
lobbying grandmaster was also known for
his fierce attacks and great imagination
over the board so be sure to check that
game out but here we have a game from
1979 and here we have really an
encounter of two towels
Michael talbert's is dragged with early
marriage and when two attackers meet the
end result is always especially if you
know one of the attackers gets
inspiration as you well a brilliant
masterpiece and well if two attackers
meet I know it often favors the Handy
attacker who got the white pieces so
let's see this game in this game it all
has the white pieces and he opens with C
Ford English opening we have C 5 but B 3
and now Knight to c6 Bishop to b2 v 5 we
have G 3 d6 Bishop to G 2 and the Bishop
to e6 Knight to c3 Queen to d7 Knight to
f3 and now valley meter which goes for
the immediate Bishop to h3 he wants to
get rid of tall strong light square
bishop so Bishop captures Queen captures
and Knight to d5 by tau and here black
has a couple of options he can well the
threat you have to prevent is of course
nice to see 7 check so you could play
rook to c8 stopping this you could go
Queen queenside castle but millimeter
which retreats with the Queen Queen to
d7 and believe leaves his options open
he would like to Castle kingside and
another thing you're playing against
style you don't want to you know castle
too early so III we have night c2 e7 and
now night back to c3 tal likes really
middle each night on the seven kind of
blocking his development so ninety to f6
we have castles by tau and now II for
thought was definitely going to push d4
at some point also rookie 1.e4 was an
idea
so the limiter which prevents this he
plays d4 and here top plays Knight to g5
now what's the idea of Knight to g5 well
firstly mmm it's its g5 is a very nice
square of course but what do you do when
this Knight gets attacked well you can
go to h3 maybe Riemann over it to f4
we'll see what happens we have d5 and
here top plays C captures on d5 and you
can't really capture this pawn even
though you're attacking it three times
if you capture with the f6 Knight then
you're no longer defending the e4 pawn
and if you try capturing good with the
seven point then after Knight captures
Queen captures you have Bishop captures
and I've six pawn captures and now
Knight to h3 Knight is ready to jump to
to f4 and it's it's a better position
for white black pawn structure is
completely messed up so well emitter
which doesn't go for this afterthought
captured on d5 he immediately went for
Queen to a5 and it seems Thomas Knight
is pretty stranded there of course you
could defend it with f4 r h4 but the
queen is blocking the 933 to h3 but this
was Todd's idea all along when he played
seek after sandy father he saw that
after the Eliminator which plays Queen
to a5 he will play a move that can't
really be calculated but it of course
offers a very interesting game so
without even trying to save the drowning
hippo tile goes for Knight captures on
f7 and now you don't really have a
option of declining this very nice
sacrifice your rupees attack time h8 if
you move the
you get nice 2d6 check you lose the
Queen
so King captures on f7 in here top plays
f3 so tau does have some compensation
but but not really any realistic
compensation he has a nice Bishop on b2
of course the knight is very nice and c3
he's trying to open up bf file because
the king is on f7 the queen is on f5 and
we'll meter which plays Knight he
captures on b5 we have F captures on e4
attacking the knight and the Queen and
now the strongest move for black
millimeter which plays at Knight
captures on c3 first the attack styles
Queen on d1 so Bishop captures on c3 and
now Queen captures on e4
so okay Todd did you get an open F file
for his rook he has a very nice bishop
on c3 but there is still no real
compensation for the piece if millimeter
which you will be able to play at any
point Bishop to e7 or Bishop to d6 and
get this rock into the game then his
extra piece will really really make a
difference so it all doesn't allow this
to happen
he plays Queen to h5 the only move that
really continues the initiative and now
you definitely don't want to play
something like King to e7 allowing Queen
captures on c5 with check
you can't block this with g6 because
we're captures on f6 is coming and the
problem with Queen to g6 is again Queen
to d5 check the knight on f6 is still
pinned King e8 now comes Queen captures
on b7 and now Tallwood you definitely
have sufficient compensation for the
piece so after this Queen to h5 check
King to e6 it's the only move the
strongest move that still gives black
the advantage but you know you have a
king and e6 against towel that's if you
want to call that an advantage that's
that's your call
Queen to h3 by towel and what do you do
here again you have to do something
against as black so naturally your first
idea would be to block it with Queen to
g4 but this of course doesn't work
because simply rook captures remove the
defender with check you pick up the
Queen
why twins so after Queen 2h2 recheck
again availa meter which goes for the
strongest move kink to d6 now again the
limiter which only has to bring this
rope into the game hide the King
developed this bishop and get the other
rope into the game and then he can
really enjoy his extra piece here your
king is on d6 as black how do you
continue the attack as white well it's
really no clear way but Tull finds one
way before he wants to open up this C
file some somehow of course black will
not capture this pawn as you know that
there's really no point in giving white
another open file so villa meter which
goes for King to c7 ready to bring the
rook into the game and hide the king
doubles rook a to c1 simply putting a
roof on a file that will soon open rook
the c8 countering the c1 rook and now
comes rock to f5 so what stars idea here
again towel doesn't have any companies
any real compensation for the peace of
allah meter which almost got away safely
which is king but he does have to make
he does have to make a move
what stalls idea what rock to f5 well if
you simply continue with your plan for
example King to b8 now you get this very
annoying Bishop to e5 check and now you
have to give up the exchange with rook
to c7 because if you play rook to e8
then comes rook captures on f6 and you
can't capture the rook because Queen
captures rook on c8 would be checkmate
so this rock to f5 moved by tal a lot
poison to it so Queen to g4 now really
matter which wants to trade Queens and
start enjoying his extra piece Talos
Bishop to e5 check not allowing the King
to escape first we have King back to the
7 and now Queen to f1 still not allowing
to trade Queens of course stall wants to
keep everything on the board and
millimeter it still didn't manage to
develop the bishop to get the DHH rook
into the game and here a move that would
definitely belong stalls attack would be
c4 you simply place C for you don't
allow the sea
to be open and then you slowly start
developing your pieces and you might be
able to survive this but philometor
vision disposition played Queen to e4
and by playing Queen to b4 he thought
okay I'll give tall some material back
but at least I'll be able to survive the
attack idea being that if not I'll place
the expected Bishop captures and f6g
captures and rook captures on f6 simply
Bishop to e7
now you're you've developed the Bishop
rook rook is coming to a fate and all is
well for black but unfortunately Tala
had a not a different idea after this
Queen to e4 move top plate Rock the c-4
now attacking the Queen and as you can
see the Queen doesn't really have
anywhere to go
only only square available for the Queen
is this c6 square so Queen to c6 and now
tau plays Queen to h3 and you should
know that Queen to h3 is far from the
best move for example white could seize
the immediate advantage with Bishop
captures on f6g captures rook captures
attacking the Queen and after the Queen
moves 25 now B captors on c5 and there
are so many threats here white white
definitely has the advantage you know
regardless of being down a piece roof to
d4 a terrible threat of winning the
Queen the rook is coming to f7 Queen can
come to a 4 so many threats black would
not be able to defend this but tal has a
different idea after this Quintus e6
move top plays Queen to h3 and this is
really hot all place just he simply
gives you so many options to make a
wrong move and here like like in many
cases when someone is threatening a
discovery when this works rook moves you
know all hell will break loose the best
thing to do is to simply get the King
out of the attack simply King to d8 and
black can still play this game but
unfortunately for millimeter which he
played Queen to e6 and thus Queen 3
sec's move allowed tau to create a
beautiful and ending for this game here
top final
play Bishop characters on f6 we have G
captors on f6 and now comes the beauty
of the game rook to e4 and this is this
is really the only move that actually
allowed tile to play this to play this
line and now you really don't have
anything to do here if you move the
Queen
for example Queen captures on e4 which
is the obvious move now the queen is on
e4 simply rook to e5 this comes with
check you can't block check so after
King moves let's say King c7 is simply
captured a queen a rook and queen will
beat two rooks and the bishop so after
this rook to e4 move villa meter which
saw that there's no point in capturing
if you if you move the Queen to any
other square you're simply gonna lose
that Queen so he played Queen captures
on a2 and now comes rock captures and
see if I would check and it was in this
position when call played rook captures
and c5 that draaga villa mirror which
resigned to the game what did he resign
well as you can see the king is in check
the rook this rook is controlling the RC
file this rook is controlling the entire
efile so King can only go to d8 or d6
and it doesn't really matter if King to
d8 then rook captures on the 8th this
will be checkmate and if you play King
to 1836 then simply rook the d4 check
and again there's really nothing to do
you can block with the Queen to
prolonged checkmate for one move or you
can go back to e7 and now Queen to d7 is
again checkmate
so a brilliant game between McHale
talent raggedly but the meter which you
know worthy of or worthy of everyone
seeing it I do hope you enjoyed it and
like I said I do recommend you check out
the valley meter which is a game I will
put a link to it in the description
below it's also it's also quite
spectacular it's you know it's not any
worse than then for example this one
that tall one against him so do check it
out and I would like to thank
background for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it I hope you are all ready
for my coverage of the 1960 World Chess
Championship match between Italian
Botvinnik I probably will start tomorrow
with the first game but in case I don't
maybe maybe I will leave it for like
Monday because I do have I do have some
tournament games coming up on Saturday
and on Sunday so yeah that that's it I
do hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon